at 506 on your Valentine's Day it's the
annual have a heart and stop for
pedestrians campaign you know somebody
dresses up as a valentine a bunch of
local police departments are joining
forces promoting safety around
crosswalks so they're going to be in the
Southeast Valley at Boulder Highway and
Whitney and the same place kind of in
the same area where they were last year
cracking down on unsafe driving but you
know what they're asking pedestrians to
make smart decisions too like only
Crossing in a marked crosswalk at least
eight pedestrians have died on our
streets just since the beginning of this
year Sherry oh that's sad to hear